yolande disposer bientôt je t'aime
épisodes de weeds tu es contente un mois
tu danses contes mais de la musique
électronique
elle m'a tout apporté non non je pense
pas très chaud là je donnais du canada
non mais vraiment non c'est j'assiste
suis pas je suis pas très chaud hier
avant la littérature la musique techno
fait
[Musique]
voir
les gars
bon en fait j'aime pas trop non c'est
parce que j'ai l'impression que tout le
monde le regarde et que je suis mais que
plus ridicule de toute la soirée sympa
ce petit soin peut-on manger des bananes
en une minute
j'étais prêt ouais ça après le bac ou
non leurs comptes donne la fessée c'est
pourquoi je pleure vous êtes qui
personne je veux pas coiffée ça
ressemble à quoi
avant premier de la classe les 18 en
maths la semaine dernière dans la vidéo
les vacances je vous dis que tu appelles
études des jeunes c'est vrai j'ai jamais
dit ça non non non je te jure je l'avais
pas dit non sucrés aimes-tu les bananes
ou non toujours pas est-ce que tu avais
dit à tes parents tu as eu un million
d'abonnés si oui comment thierry lâché
je me suis bien que j'aie dire la mer et
que c'est une soirée vraiment mémorable
à elle avait l'air vraiment extrêmement
fier de moi et tout ça c'est passé un
peu comme ça non j'ai atteint les 1
million d'abonnés
ok cool tu as eu ton assez dans la
cuisine on va manger si tu avais un
super pouvoir ce serait quoi j'aurai un
pouvoir d'en faire je pourrait sauver
des milliers voire des millions veuves
et je serai manama pour nous au foot
lors de forts
les événements ayant pris une tournure
dramatique bad and i'm a décidé à
compter de ce jour de prendre sa
retraite
quel était ton dessin animé préféré
quand tu étais petit non c'est pas toi
c'est beau non mais tu ne peux pas
arrête ton char est un psychopathe ah
oui et alors je suis l'être le plus
diabolique de la planète
j'aime être à bout ces contacts et jeune
greffé de m et mon chien vous à chante
parce qu'il me fait chier
comment tu te vois dans dix ans mais je
pense que j'aurai pris ma vie en main
que je remontais une boîte et je
recruterai plein de jeunes pour les
aider dans la vie et qu'on fera des
choses incroyables tous ensemble et tout
ou alors peut-être comme ça aussi
si demain c'est la fin du monde que fais
tu merci tu ressembles hommen dans
cyprien gaming
oui chanter sous la douche et si oui
quoi comme 80% des personnes oui je
chante sous la douche et j'aime bien
chanter question un peu ghetto un peu
hardcore de l'afrique rue et où tu as vu
peux tu nous faire une vidéo de parcours
[Musique]
oh
thomas
[Musique]
à
au balo
abattoir du tout
[Musique]